yeah the faces on the fruit totally
creepy factor I think that's kind of
what makes it fun it's campy it's weird
it's a little scary at times I think
what adds to the creepiness too is a lot
of people still discover this after
watching it for years but it's the same
eye it's two left eyes and not one
they're not both eyes it's we do it that
way because it's easier for animation
but I think that actually adds to the
creepy factor plus they don't have noses
and whatever but I love that style of
animation I always have and you know
back it started off with Clutch Cargo I
remember watching the thumb movies was
it like thumb thumb wars Franken thumb
all that stuff I love that style of
animation so that's kind of what
inspired me yes I guess it was to a
degree I mean I was always kind of
aiming for that tween audience because
that's you know that's kind of that big
audience on YouTube and you know that
was the intention so yeah from the
beginning definitely was trying to hit
kids young the kids and tweens probably
it's funny because that was one of the
biggest questions that people ask is how
do you take something that's two minutes
long it's just an annoying orange you
know silly jokes whatever how do you
adapt that to a TV show and it was way
easier than I ever thought it would be
because it's all about character
development you know wherein you have
just a couple minutes to make somebody
laugh on the web you now have 11 minutes
to really flush out a story the
characters and their relationships with
one another and that actually was a huge
part of what made a lot of fun is
playing with those dynamics even further
we kind of established it on the web and
we really got to flourish
got to the TV show as far as merch goes
I think definitely like the TV show the
web show and the merchandise everything
Annoying Orange has to all work together
otherwise it kind of falls apart so we
have to make sure that you know we have
enough merchandise out there enough
variations of merchandise we have to
make sure that the TV show is running
it's doing well all that stuff for all
of it to swim together it's really cool
to see all of the kids like constantly
tweet pictures at me and orange about
like hey I just found this in this in
the store and this is awesome
check it out and it's you know gummies
or shirts or whatever it might be a lot
of times kids will send me stuff and
I'll be like I don't even remember
approving that that is hilarious I guess
trying to yeah I mean we're trying to do
all kinds of things on the channel
whether it may be animation live-action
stop-motion whatever whatever is funny
to us I mean we're just I've surrounded
myself with a lot of really awesome
creative people like Spencer Grove
he was the writer that was with me
originally with the series when it's
first started and he's been you know my
partner and crime as far as like coming
up with you know ideas for this show and
then new IPs and then like Luke brats
he's he's another great writer he worked
on the TV show he's from brats and
Bretta he's been helping us out
immensely and I don't know if he met
Aaron Aaron's a great guy he is he's
helping us out and it's just surrounding
yourself with really great creative
people and it's fun to get in the room
and just start tossing out the ideas for
new IPs and it's it's it's great because
we just we all sit around and laugh and
you know we'll throw out ideas that
completely don't work but you know
that's part of the process is it's fun
to you know come up with that idea that
does work eventually yes though I think
that's kind of what we want to do is
make annoying orange a destination we of
course Orange Friday episodes will kind
of be the staple always but surrounding
that with
all kinds of stuff whether it be new IPs
or gaming or whatever yeah just build it
out so on the annoying lawrence channel
we're kind of building it out and making
all kinds of new projects on there all
kinds of new IPs the first one we just
did was the misfortune of being ned he's
this plucky kid really you know he's
excited about everything but
unfortunately something good happens to
him at the beginning of the episode and
because of it something really bad
happens to him so there's a lot of
cartoon violence and fun things like
that that kind of annoying orange is
known for and that was a lot of fun too
because it was outside it was a
different kind of animation we did like
flash animation for it beyond that we're
doing the marshmallow show marshmallow
is one of our biggest characters on the
channel and now marshmallow is getting
their own show
so that's gonna be a lot of fun there's
gonna be a lot of rainbows and kittens
and you know youtuber cameos it'll be
it'll be awesome and then beyond that we
have got a bunch of stuff in the works
we've got a puppet show music show and a
bunch of other things that I can't say
quite yet but I think are gonna be
really awesome and just a lot of fun to
do on my main channel we just did six
episodes of a series called thunder make
wild which is a little bit more adult
themed it's you know that's why we put
it on that channel there's a few more
adult themes than Annoying Orange would
allow it's about a retired street
fighter who is now trying to make it in
this Indian he's trying to live his life
in the normal world but unfortunately
his strength is just too much for
everything so a lot of funny situations
come from that so right now there is not
an annoying orange movie but that is
something that I am definitely working
towards I would love to do an annoying
orange movie I think I think that would
be one of the big next steps
I mean we've established this great cast
of characters and they've got a each one
of them has great backstories and I
think it'd be fun to explore those
backstories kind of see how they all
came together all of that stuff big
grand adventure I mean ultimately the
the biggest good thing about YouTube is
that it is offered the opportunity for
so many people to do this for a living
I guess maybe that would be the
number-one thing for me it's cuz I you
know was just just scraping by I come
from a family that that went bankrupt
and so to go from basically having
nothing to be able to do the kind of
things that I love for a living it's
pretty amazing and I will you know I
will always be extremely appreciative of
of youtube for allowing me to you know
be able to do that it's a great place to
build an audience you know to get
instant feedback with people to get
notes on your work you know that instant
feedback of like oh this sucks or oh
this is awesome do this again that's
actually really valuable as a creator
and so you know just being able to have
something like that where it's so easy
to to work with your fans is pretty
awesome
really the biggest thing that has
impacted us and so many people are the
algorithm changes that we don't really
get an insight as to what those
algorithm changes are discovery for your
videos it's been really frustrating
because they've seemed like they've put
such a huge emphasis on subscribers but
that number means almost nothing because
person personally we have you know 3.5
million subscribers on our channel we
get maybe a fraction of that per video
and that's across the board that's not
just us that's everybody and it's
frustrating that you know we go to these
big events and YouTube's like
subscribers subscribers we're gonna you
know we're gonna get people to subscribe
to your stuff it's like that's great but
how do you get those subscribers to
watch your videos that's the more
important part I think that's been one
of the most frustrating things for me as
a creator and for us as creators is the
subscriber number is a great number to
throw around but at the end of the day
if it doesn't really mean anything
then you know wait I don't really
understand why we're concentrating so
much on that the biggest tip I would
give people just starting out is control
your distribution control if you can
control your distribution and your
social media where people find your
stuff where people get updates about you
if you can control that you are in the
driver's seat you know four craters out
there just starting out or who you know
kind of in that mid-range whatever set
yourself up a website whatever it may be
make that destination your place where
your fans can go to see your stuff to
get updates about you if you can control
that you control your destiny it sounds
cheesy but it's it's kind of true hey
guys thanks for watching up hey guys
thanks for watching this you know I'll
probably do this like 18 times I
apologize hey guys thanks for watching
up hey guys thanks for watching this
interview on new media rocks
alright guys thank you very much for
watching this interview for new media
rockstars make sure to go to new media
rockstars com2 check out the full
interview and photo shoot that I did if
you want to see more stuff of mine
please go to youtube.com slash annoying
orange or youtube.com slash daneboe
alright thanks guys
nice house that